Hey Andrea.
We created illustrations of those acorns
and family photos that you provided us,
and
we added them as images into the app.
Here, take a look.
>> This is so cool.
Look at these family member icons.
This one looks just like my grandmother.
And the colors, and the acorns.
This is starting to really feel great.
>> Yeah, everything's coming
together really well.
>> But I think there's one
more feature we can add.
>> What's that?
Well, the ability to hear the correct
pronunciation of each word.
>> Pronunciation is really
important in learning a language.
It's been the hardest thing for me.
>> That's true, and
in order to do that we need an audio
file of each word being spoken.
Andrea, could you records
some audio files for us?
>> Sure.
I'll have to brush up
on my pronunciation.
>> Don't worry.
You're going to do great.
Let's go into the recording studio
to make those sound clips, then.
>> So while they're doing that,
let's get back to the course map.
All right, so right now we're at lesson
four out of our four lesson course.
We're in the homestretch now.
Now in this lesson, we're going to first
allow the user to play an audio file to
hear the pronunciation of
each word when they touch it.
Next we're going to learn about
Android's activity lifecycle and
also learn how to properly clean up
resources in the right callbacks.
Now, here's a diagram of the activity
life cycle that we'll be discussing more
in detail later.
Now, onward.